thank you all for being here thank you
for letting me speak today I'm my name's
Stephanie Kim I'm gonna talk about
investigating user experience with a
natural language analysis
so this talk focuses on the methodology
and intent of stating feedback form and
other users our messaging data with our
tools and libraries for natural language
processing and machine learning so I'll
discuss potential trouble areas of
starting such a project from scratch
from a developer's perspective so
shocker I'm a developer but I also do
some data science work and it's usually
on doing natural language processing so
I love to help people build better
products by learning what users are
thinking and trying to understand how
they're feeling using machine learning
and text analysis so in 2012 I believe
it was I founded the Seattle PI ladies
location and currently I'm a developer
advocate and software engineer at
algorithmic and I also spend a lot of my
time increasing my own knowledge and
educating others on racial bias in AI so
shameless plug if you're gonna be around
for a Reilly AI I think it's like next
week I'm gonna be back or ods the East
and Boston come check out my racial bias
talk it's really important subject so
I'd love to see any of you there so just
a quick blurb about the guys who pay the
bills so algorithm you know we believe
that every application will eventually
become an intelligent application but as
my boss and CTO kenny daniel said
tensorflow is open source scaling it's
not so on our platform data scientists
and enterprise customers can
productionize their models and minutes
and turn them into scalable REST API
endpoints and they can privatize open
source or even monetize their models for
other developers to call on our open
marketplace so at the end of the talk
they'll be a promo code if you wanna try
us out I'll give you some free credits
so now let's get to the good stuff so
again this talk will cover the benefits
of investigating your user data we'll
talk about the types of helpful
techniques that are commonly used in
this kind of analysis and I'll talk
about you know what did you when the
model is not performing very well and
then what to do with the insights that
you that you gained so why investigate
user feedback
you know we reuse their messages that
come in whether you're using feedback
from vendors such as for CEO or user a
messaging data under like intercom you
know often we read these messages when
we have time but we don't get to look at
overall trends so users have some really
important insights and suggestions for
making your product better so it's
really important to know what they're
talking about so the goal is to increase
your awareness of what users are
thinking and feeling from a high-level
view and as I said as I mentioned you
want to look at those trends but then
you want to get those messages to the
appropriate teams so you can help your
users be happier and more successful
using your product so by analyzing
feedback you can find hidden trends and
patterns doing sentiment or even topic
based time series analysis you can find
bugs and design issues that might have
been missed in QA by doing anomaly
detection you can even gain me
opportunities try an a/b test based off
user feedback prioritize user messages
based off of topic or sentiment and then
respond accordingly
and then you can also learn about as I
said feature requests or needs from the
users they're the ones using it the most
they're the ones that it might be
failing on so you can also do
segmentation and targeted messaging for
instance you can identify all the
unhappy customers or people who asked
for certain features and reach out to
them specifically if you have
non-anonymous data so if you that's a
lot of stuff that you could do with user
messaging and feedback form data so
about that data user feedback form data
is notoriously dirty like disgustingly
dirty um some more than others
intercom data is the force that I've
touched if you first see a feedback form
data is actually not too bad so you're
gonna be looking at having to strip out
HTML tags grammatical errors now some
things that you might want to take out
for a document classification that you
want might want to keep for sentiment
classification are things like swear
words and emoticon like text which you'd
want to transform into some kind
touken a sentiment classifier would pick
up so note that for these slides I
they're based on intercom data which we
use that algorithm and in the past
education group I have used foresee a
feedback form data so you also want to
make sure you create your custom stop
word lists and I like to ignore super
short comments that contain less than
some threshold of tokens I usually pick
3 tokens
once all the stop words are taken out so
I love this isn't insightful data for
information retrieval purposes but it
can be insightful for sentiment scores
especially if you if you know like it
say you're running an AP test and you
know exactly you know what form was it
was changed in a certain way then that
sentiment might be useful so make sure
you keep in your goals in mind when
you're cleaning your data so of course
you'd also want to use a stammer or a
lemma tiser and you'd want to increase
versity with our remove sparse words or
if you're in Python and you might use
count vectorizer to help develop more
meaningful clusters in your data and
decrease the chance of creating them all
that overfits to your data so and by the
way I didn't mention so I said I'm a
developer I actually do Python and are I
have been using are more and more lately
so don't tell the pilot is Shh
so let's first address what you all
probably already know about performance
that when performance is your top
priority and you're working with large
data datasets you want to use data table
which skills better than data frames so
this is because data frames make a deep
copy and that means that it copies the
entire data frame to another location in
memory and so it clogs down your machine
and when you're working with really
large data sets that could be a long way
of doing nothing but staring at your
laptop process are just that fun so when
performance isn't your top priority
because a lot of us actually don't work
with big data you might want to use deep
liar for its readability flexibility and
that a nice abstracted data layer when
you need to connect to different data
sources
I really I'm a big fan of deep layers
syntax I use it a lot regardless you
should use data tables F read function
versus read CSV when consuming static
data files because read CSV is super
slow you've got a major win on speed
using F read so if you're dealing with
you know data that I mean you're dealing
with larger data sets you'll want to use
F read because it processes the it
inputs the data immediately as
characters whereas read CSV first tries
to convert the data into integers and
factors and all this other stuff and
you're waiting a little bit longer you
also might want to try this is not a
package I've tried yet but I'm really
curious about playing around with it
it's Microsoft our open library which is
Microsoft's re-release of revolution
analytics are open it's a company who
Microsoft acquired a while back so
Microsoft are open has a packet that
package allows for multi-threaded
capabilities that speed up comma matrix
operations by quite a bit by using all
cores through a parallel processing now
you will have to depend on Intel's math
kernal library to take advantage of it
so it's another dependency you know to
think about and they also have I believe
paid libraries as well that are even
faster I again I haven't checked out any
of those but it's kind of on my to-do
list so now that we've covered what you
should think about as far as libraries
and your data before you get started
analyzing let's talk about the types of
analysis that might be helpful so you
know when you're thinking about
investigating user data you'll probably
start with some basic text mining
techniques in order to find patterns in
your data so you'll be doing some
unsupervised clustering such as k-means
or dendrograms or use topic modeling
with Lda and then you'll likely want to
move to sentiment analysis document
classification or even time series or
anomaly detection as as I go along we'll
cover what models you would use for
these different types of use cases and
the insights you can gain from them so
first you might want to find
patent patterns or topics in your data
so you can use different unsupervised
techniques such as in the sly there's a
k-means clustering that's used but I
actually kind of preferred dendrograms
there's just a little bit harder to the
you know see on the screen you could do
word clouds named entity recognition and
more and so on the upper left there's a
cluster with the terms ear image
colorize we shall talk about later but I
want to point out that a lot of these
unsupervised techniques the ones that I
mentioned probably are gonna produce
similar results because many of them use
euclidean distance so they'll give you
similar clusters but different
visualizations so it's probably not
worth your time to create all of them
for one analysis so choose the one that
that's best fits your goal not that I've
you know spent time creating like every
visualization or anything no I wouldn't
do that for instance if you're
generating reports then maybe choose one
with a nice visualization like I said I
like tender grams that way you could see
the hierarchy of clustered words that
often appear together but say you're
prepping for document class okay cute
classification then you're gonna
probably want to skip this and just go
to LD a to get you know your tot
documents by topics so again keep those
goals in mind
so you don't waste time going down a
rabbit hole so if you want to satisfy
your own curiosity about what users are
thinking about the most and give your
place to start when thinking about
document classification or other
information retrieval tasks such as
creating the topic labels for Lda you
can use the term frequency chart so
you'll probably want to use diagrams
versus you know grams or trigrams but
test with your own data to see what
works the best for you I've done this
project I think three times at two
different companies and I've
consistently found by grams to work the
best for this type of data so this
background frequency is using tf-idf
don't think I need to describe what that
is but in case it's a statistic that
measures the relative importance of an
Engram it's the whole document so in our
case the five top terms our machine
learning sentiment analysis deep
learning error message and API key
and that Aramis is just that my grandma
keeps popping up so but we want to do
Lda and Lda requires bag-of-words
so you can see he is the top by Graham's
changed a little bit so if you're doing
document classification but your user
messages aren't labeled with topics yet
yeah I love all these LD gate and
document classification search for the
document classification tutorials always
assume you have label data but a lot of
times that's not true so you can use LD
a which is a topic modeler that
discovers topics and documents and
assigns probabilities to those terms
making up the document or making up the
topics so notice on our slide we have
terms that make up a topic and behind
the scenes they have probabilities
assigned to them that indicate how well
they fit into that grouping but note
that we don't have any labels for topics
yet so looking at topic three we could
possibly infer this about people asking
questions regarding deploying their
model talbert's meanwhile topic four
might be about problems using on how to
use the Python client pythons are
probably our most popular language on
the marketplace I would say ours
probably the most popular in the
enterprise side so going back to the
term frequency chart we might decide to
call a topic for error message or we
could be more specific and call it
Python error message so these results
came from the topic models package from
tidy text which uses Gibbs sampling but
note that there are a lot of other Lda
models available in R such as text Tyvek
and the mallet package and I think I
haven't tried the text Tyvek package but
Mallett tends to give pretty good
results so LD is so easy to implement on
your data and you should definitely test
these all out to see what gives you the
best results but I want to make a note
that text avec is likely going to be the
most performant because it's based on
warp l da which is memory efficient so
after you've done your l da you need to
map your documents to their associated
topics so again we before we just had
the topics but we need to create the
labels for those two
this document had 60% probability of
belonging in this topic
it was probably LD a called it topic
four or something like that
which I decided to call client API Aires
so node client option request server
response cores error would have the
label client API errors and that label I
made up based off of my domain knowledge
I'd then use these mappings to create a
training set for document classification
since I don't already have a label data
set so the end goal here is that you
know you have your topics and they're
mapped to documents and now you can do
some investigation into the UI and find
out areas that users might be having
trouble with so a my previous job at
Apollo education group I found that
people were having trouble using a
confusing drop-down and so it wasn't
actually a bug it was a a UI issue so
also um an algorithm yeah
after manually reading the documents
that mapped to the topics found in the
previous slide I revisited our Python
Docs client Docs and our modal model
hosting Docs and I decided to just make
them a little bit clearer for beginners
and do a little bit more hand-holding in
the documentation so and now that you
have these label documents again you can
train the model for document
classification speaking of which now
we'll go through some types of models
you might want to try for classification
tasks so whether you're training a
document or a sentiment classification
model most models accuracy and
performance depends upon how many
classes you're trying to classify on and
how large of a data set you have access
to so more classes require more data
which is you know really important when
you're looking at document
classification you don't want to have
too many classes so here are some broad
guidelines but again you really have to
test your own data on various models to
see what will work best on your data set
so many people's go to naive Bayes
especially if you don't have a ton of
data but if you have some more data and
you want a more robust small you could
try random forests but
that choosing random forest will give
you most likely a boost in accuracy but
you'll lose speed which is really
important in real world applications if
your production production izing your
model so usually a naivebayes is good
enough for the real world
so for decent accuracy but kind of a
lack of scalability because of word
embeddings are little slow you might
want to try words avec via word vectors
package in our text avec which i already
mentioned which is similar to pythons
docked avec or even LD 8 avec which
combines word Tyvek word embeddings with
lDA's topic modeling i am really curious
to use that one I haven't played around
with it yet but that's another mi to-do
list so when you don't have enough data
to train your model especially like if
you only have maybe a year's worth or
less of user messaging data don't
discard the many pre train sentiment
models out there or has some and you
know other there are other open source
sentiment pre train models out there so
feedback form data is fairly similar to
social data so it has a lot of
misspelled words fragmented sentences
emoticons Lang etc so it's useful to
check out pre train models if you don't
have enough data to train your own so
lastly if you have the infrastructure
available for GPUs and you have a lot of
data for each class and time is on your
side for training then you can use deep
learning I wouldn't suggest like that
being your starting point but you could
try convolutional neural nets for
classification tasks and that way you
won't have to focus on future
engineering and you should get pretty
good results but that's not always the
case so definitely not the place to
start out with so make sure you
understand your priorities are you
looking for performance or are you
looking for accuracy and based decisions
on your data size and the your available
infrastructure alright so one of the
most useful analysis you can do on user
data is just discover how user sentiment
changes over time so you're looking at
you know your message data on a daily
basis that's really hard to see trends
so but even more insightful is when you
integrate release dates as benchmarks in
order to gauge sentiment changes so say
you have a major design release or maybe
even in a demo of one your API is
released in the wild and you want to
find out how users felt about it a
little foreshadowing there so notice the
spike in negative sentiment it has to do
with that cluster we found in the
k-means slide that you know by gram
error message but honestly I'm still too
traumatized to talk about it
so did depending on the vendor I already
mentioned a couple of vendors that
people use for collecting user message
data you might be lucky to enough to
have the URI that the former comment was
made on and that way you can aggregate
sentiment by pages so for example if you
have if you want to find the sentiment
scores for a landing page and you can
run and you're running a be tests on
different styles you can gain extra
insight the beyond conversion rates and
pull out the negative comments to see
what issues users were having with that
style but I want to mention again here
that while we're looking at the overall
trends we're then drilling down with a
more narrowed scope to view our highest
priority areas and then we're checking
those messages manually and responding
accordingly
because machine learning and automation
only goes so far and understanding what
users are thinking and how they're
feeling
so besides sentiment you could do a time
series analysis on topics so I'm finally
ready to talk about what happened in mid
2000 mid 2017 to get such somber
clusters and sentiment so this slide
shows a huge spike that occurred for the
bigram err message and this was due to a
demo we created for colorizer algorithm
that developers could use in their apps
to colorize their black-and-white photos
via our API so the reason we're getting
so many user messages that contain the
bigram error message and such negative
cements and our user messaging was that
the demo landed on a few genealogy and
photography sites and non developers
were sending us messages
that they were having difficulties
uploading their black-and-white images
to our demo they thought this was like
just software that they could use to and
it was it was just a simple simple demo
to show how easy it was to you know call
the colorizer
algorithm via our API so at the time we
found these messages manually but if you
have a live data stream and are building
out really cool real-time dashboards you
might want to track a few important
engrams that you can either get from the
frequency char that we looked at or the
topics from a topic modeler like Lda and
that way you can get a feel of what
users are talking about and set up
alerts to notify if it's over under a
certain threshold for anomaly detection
so you could see even with this
completely unexpected example it's
really helpful to track what users are
talking about in real time so that you
can help them use your app your API or
in this case where you direct them to an
iOS up to color is there black and white
photos when they aren't your target user
so if you want to do time series to
understand overall trends in your data
and even forecast future trends and
topics or sentiment you might want to
try some of the models shown on the
slide I'm not going to go into details
but a quick cap auto regressive
integrated moving average is kind of my
go-to and it's the one I know best so I
usually do that for some quick
forecasting and then on the slide for
sentiment analysis I believed I use Holt
winters which has a triple exponential
smoothing model so I couple weeks ago
actually I was I was doing some Google
searches on stuff and I came across
profit which there was an awesome talk
about yesterday so I did a really quick
proof of concept it's super easy to get
up and running with that unfortunately
it kept crashing our when I tried to
plot it so I've got some debugging work
to do to figure that out but it's a
super user-friendly really fast to get
up and running so I suggest checking
that out if you're looking to detect
anomalies such as our colorizer spike
you could use
port vector machine algorithm or K
nearest neighbor Twitter has also put
out a promising anomaly detection model
that's available for our called anomaly
detection
I haven't played around with that one
yet but I've heard good things so
definitely another one to check out so
and of course I have to talk about one
of our algorithm developers just put out
a generative forecasting model called
generative forecast and anomaly
detection model called threshold anomaly
detection I haven't checked out either
I'm gonna be honest about that based a
pretty talented guys we might want to
look at those two so and of course if
you have a ton of data and you again you
have the infrastructure to train your
model you might want to look at a RNN
variant long short-term memory model
which has really good results for
anomaly detection and other
classification problems and that's due
to Ellis team's ability to recall older
information from previous passes in the
network that other neural nets don't
include so with time series anomaly
detection you can detect and then
prioritize your groups of users that
have problems using your product or site
and then respond to them quickly and
triage the issue to the appropriate team
lead so sometimes your model is not
performing how am i doing on time Oh way
over I'm so sorry
okay so okay we're done and that's okay
I
I'll post these slides up somewhere so
here you could take a picture of the
promo code if you want to check this out
thank you so much for having me
[Applause]
you